welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and spider-man new way home is now
available in higher resolution and now
that i can actually pause and look at
the stuff instead of begging the amc
projectionist to freeze the frame i know
that's you back there nicole kidman
folks there is so much more hidden in
this movie that we just gotta re-break
down this film some of this will be
stuff that i found on my first breakdown
on release weekend which has grown to be
my most viewed video ever thank you all
so much so to show my gratitude to you
and to the talented artists who worked
on this film i have found well over 100
more details i think my final tally is
close to 200 that i am going to present
to you in this comprehensive near
shot-by-shot analysis of everything
great about spider-man no way home but i
am going to streamline this and make it
less about my commentary now that we've
all seen the film and big thanks to boxu
for sponsoring this video more on their
tasty offerings later okay over the
studio titles we actually hear
mysterio's audio from the post-credits
scene of spider-man far from home i
managed to send the elemental back to
the dimensional rate but i don't think
i'm gonna make it off this bridge alive
in his dying moments mysterio maintained
the lie of his illusions coming from an
interdimensional rift all the doom peter
parker but also ironically actual
threats coming from dimensional rifts
become the actual crisis in this movie's
final battle the marvel studios title
card has been updated so that on the r
replacing rocket is peter's portal
arrival and end game now just a little
tease for the way this movie will bring
back other peters through the same kinds
of portals far from home of course ended
with the credits cutting off peter's
f-bomb
[Music]
here a car horn censors it
the scene has been recreated almost
exactly down to the three extras behind
mj dressed just like the guys behind her
in the 2019 scene the even game the dude
with the phone wired earbuds just like
he had before attention to detail but
the main difference of course is that mj
now wears the broken black dahlia
necklace that peter bought for her in
venice and gave to her in london to
which she said
sorry it's broken
i actually like it better broken mj
knows things can never be perfect her
mantra is expect disappointment and you
will never get disappointed and that is
why she refuses to let peter say i love
you in order to leave things broken give
him a reason to find her one onlooker
asks are you just a kid a nod of that
onlooker on the train at sam raimi
spider-man 2 in 2004 when toby mcguire
was unmasked he's
just a kid that peter's exposure was met
with gratitude leaving him with faith in
humanity but this peter's exposure is
met with hostility leaving him more
cynical as they swing through the city
they pass billboards for rogers and
musical which we saw in hawkeye and will
return in secret invasion there are also
billboards for fortnite and the hyundai
ioniq 5 which did a cross-promotional
campaign with the film its slogan
electrify your journey of course tying
in with electro there's also a
playstation billboard because sony these
screens show peter's face with this mask
covering half of it a recurring image
that we've seen in the comics they land
on queensborough bridge with the nearby
roosevelt island tramway the same
location as the final showdown in the
2002 film they dropped past flash on his
phone as a tick-tock feed of the daily
bugle official the account hosted by
betty brant leading up to the film's
release they pop out in front of del
mar's deli now labeled del mars 3 as
this is the third film in this trilogy
and we have seen this bodega destroyed
at least once the sign reads best
sandwiches in queens calling back mr del
mar's line in homecoming best sandwiches
in queens and they're coming out of the
sewer actually because in queens the
subway turns into an elevated train as
we see in the background john watts
leaves the camera on a close-up of the
manhole cover and since throughout these
opening minutes we're getting a ton of
shout outs to the past eras this has
gotta be a call back to the closing shot
of the amazing spider-man 2. they land
outside peter's bedroom
[Music]
oh my god to help her in peter
accidentally grabs her butt and
immediately says i'm sorry aunt may and
happy walk in on peter and mj a call
back to may walking in on peter's
shirtless with ned and homecoming mj
hands peter his i survived my trip to
nyc shirt that he wore in homecoming
also in this apartment his poster for
the feast fundraiser where spider-man
made his appearance and far from home
john watts directed the sequence in one
two-minute long take to heighten the
comedic awkwardness in which tom holland
and zendaya impressively scramble around
this place when peter thwips the first
shade shut the animators made sure to
show that webbing shooting out of his
arm in his reflection in the cabinet and
when the last shade shoots back up it
looks like tom might actually improvise
webbing it shut in order to keep it down
jay jonah jameson's graphic shows
protester signs calling for peter to be
locked up another calling him a criminal
with devil horns this awkward photo of
peter is actually his passport photo
that we saw in the far from home deleted
scene and then over on the far right is
a sign reading it was better when you
were blipped in jay jonah's home studio
is a wall with the trio of terror front
page as well as an us weekly that
compares mj to liz allen using the photo
of her from the academic decathlon in dc
and homecoming another headline reports
mysterio douses hydro man in venice
because in far from home they initially
thought the elemental in venice was the
longtime spidey villain hydra man morris
bench jameson also has some spare
bottles of his supplements throughout
the place showing how his whole new
fancy studio the whole business was
really paid for by those pills the daily
news front page has photoshopped peter
mj and ned using their yearbook photos
and for the first time we see mj's last
name watson making michelle jones watson
the variant of mary jane watson of this
universe time magazine calls peter iron
man jr how did a reckless teenager
become tony stark's heir apparent all
this echoing the same sentiments of team
mysterio from far from home as if this
could have been headlined that they
scripted for the media peter gets coated
in green paint this is actually from a
deleted scene with tom holland's brother
harry holland you'll notice the graffiti
behind peter reads ramos for umberto
ramos a longtime spider-man comic artist
who partnered with dan slott
international news is a ticker reporting
interpal issues arrest warrant for czech
republic's night monkey showing how
european police are still unsure if
spider-man and night monkey for far from
home are the same person and then
political turmoil continues in new
asgard suggesting that king of
valkyrie's rule over that colony is
struggling something we could see more
of in love and thunder the b-roll they
show of tower bridge shows none of the
drones in the open air or spider-man's
heroics but just the moments when he and
mysterio were obscured in the tower
walkway as peter wrecked those drones
showing more of team mysterio's
manipulations because if they showed
peter fighting those drones that would
hurt the narrative that team mysterio
wanted out there that it was peter
controlling the drones dodc agent cleary
named seen on his badge is a nod to
agent albert cleary the dodc comptroller
in the comics photographs are taken of a
photo of ned and mj from homecoming as
well as peter's iron spider charging
point all these cables plugged into one
outlet but you'll notice the armor
itself is missing we see tony's eateth
glasses from far from home that case
just left open showing how peter must
see this every day as a reminder of tony
and it's on a stack of ps2 games because
sony also this peter parker is a
scavenger who goes dumpster diving for
old consoles and stuff now during the
interrogation peter where's his the
physics are theoretical but the fun is
real shirt that he wore when tony
dropped him off back home in homecoming
agent cleary says nick fury has been off
planet for the last year
what yes nick fury and far from home was
actually the talos a story line that
we're probably going to revisit in
secret invasion now i'm wondering if
cleary but the fact that he knows this
could also be a scroll clear he's able
to get ned to confess by tricking him
into correcting his misstatement when mj
told you that peter was spider-man
what's up i knew way before mj did i was
spiderman's guy in the chair and a fun
detail here compared to mj's observation
room that you see in the reflection
ned's room has way more agents watching
as they all know this is a suspect who's
gonna squeal now the news also uses a
photo of happy hogan from his look from
the iron man 3 prologue that was set in
1999 when he dressed like travolta and
pulp fiction and then matt murdock
enters to which we will all applaud with
the standing o that he deserves
that's great
thank you
but i love how the dialogue here is a
total meta commentary on the insanity of
this moment peter says what is happening
because indeed charlie cox matt murdock
in the mcu does raise a lot of questions
about the canonicity of all the netflix
marvel series and charlie's first words
are that's great thank you because this
is simply great and i'm sure charlie is
pretty grateful for it now john favreau
if you remember played foggy nelson in
the 2003 ben affleck daredevil which
charlie cox said he and favreau tried to
reference in a line that got cut and
there was a line i think it got cut i
don't think it made it in the final
thing but there was a line where
he was trying to remember something
that happened and he and he he said
yeah i i can't remember what happened
i'm a little foggy about that behind
peter is another newspaper that we saw
on jameson's wall web of destruction
showing peter's damage at the staten
island ferry and the washington monument
homecoming and tower bridge and far from
home but matt murdock proves he does
have his daredevil reflexes
but i love how peter's hand was already
ready there to catch that brick because
he has spider sense and on that brick
the person misspelled the word believe
as if refusing to write the word lie in
front of mysterio they move into happy's
condo
yeah notice how may punches in the right
code on her first try probably because
happy's passcode was something like one
two three four pretty sad lapse in
security that we learn in far from home
what's your password
password now what is your password
password the word spelled out password
you're the head of security and your
password is password i don't feel good
about it either we see several of
happy's security badges calling back him
telling everyone to wear their badges in
iron man 3 but he actually might have
swiped a bunch on his way out knowing
that his clearance was going to be
revoked so he could have used someone
else's badge to steal all that star tech
notice how peter carries all five of
those heavy suitcases just a cool little
detail showing how strong the kid is
happy of course says the dummy robot
from the iron man films that we saw him
bickering with in homecoming good yes
yeah no no put that down that's worth
more than you or me but now he clearly
just misses tony you can also see his
boxing mask and gloves on the table a
callback to his boxing days we saw iron
man 2. now in the credits of this movie
they shout out downton abbey which is a
call back to him loving downton abbey
and iron man 3 but folks you never see
it in the movie in our previous
breakdown we just pointed some random
frame on the shelf saying that was down
to naby but it wasn't so anyone else who
has that in their video just clearly
watched ours install it from us anyway
on the bridge is a drawing morgan made
of her and happy there's actually
another one later in the laundry area oh
but now that stark industries was shut
down she'll be stealing her crayons from
applebee's like we did in the background
we hear the
the captain american news on the statue
of liberty
that's ridiculous
yeah details throughout this movie
foreshadow the statue of liberty final
act and how most people in new york are
against putting cap's shield on that
statue the shield falling is what almost
causes mj to fall to her death and it's
literally on that shield where peter
almost makes his worst decision so
really the people in new york were right
from the get-go this shield being added
to the statue's bad news subtle detail
that's pretty hard to spot behind that
start crate happy also boosted the iron
man painting and the style of the obama
hook poster from iron man 2 and on the
nighttime security monitor you can also
see that he swiped the recreation of the
cap's shield that tony and coulson had
in that movie when they facetime mj's
reading maya angelou's i know why the
caged bird sings she always reads
celebrated progressive authors and on
her wall is that photo of her ned from
homecoming also a photo that she took of
pigeons in venice and far from home and
the drawings she drew of peter and coach
wilson in homecoming oh i know i just
like coming here to sketch people in
crisis
it's you betty brant says
go get him tiger which of course is mary
jane's catchphrase for peter in the
comics and in the 2004 film go get him
tiger a supporter screams
[Music]
this is darnold aptly an actor in
zendaya's longtime assistant also among
that shouting we hear
i s
a flip guy return for a vocal cameo
after we saw him in homecoming okay
spiderman
don't flip
yeah
and after he returned in a cameo on that
bus in shanghai it's your boy cliff
coming at you live on the bus i actually
did take a little bit of martial arts as
a youth so i'm gonna try and grade this
fight as we're going flash thompson
shows off his memoir flashpoint it's
titled a nod of the dc comics major
crossover event inside we see the mural
of scientists how it's been expanded
from just howard stark in previous films
and all the other famous real world
scientists to include abraham erskine as
well as hank pym and then if you look
closely standing on george washington
carver's head a shrunken ant-man with a
nearby pym particle vial mr harrington's
display shows a photo of peter and mj
and venice that he clearly photoshopped
himself into but also on that yearbook
page under chess club is a photo of that
blip girl sue lorman mentioned in far
from home though it looks like she's
given a different name here flash's
photo is a professional portrait that
was taken outside so fancy and then all
the cards in this display actually lists
famous spider-man comics writers peter
unmasked by j.m strzenski that's a nod
to j michael scherzinski who wrote the
peter unmasked issue of the civil war
comics also worth the famous one more
day storyline that is based on t defalco
or tom defalco k bousiek for kurt busiek
and p david or peter david all of them
amazing spider-man comics writers as
peter walks down that hall on that
screen in the upper right is a black and
white film now i asked people on twitter
if they could identify this matthew on
twitter pointed out that this is the
same cafeteria from the movie love simon
and although this scene is not from love
simon that movie did shoot in the same
atlanta high school as john watts shot
these spider-man movies so this is
actually a side short film that john
watts shot on location here in this
school because before he directed the
spider-man movie he worked with a short
film group called waverly flams all
those shorts you could still find on
youtube now on the roof graffiti shows
ditko for spider-man co-creator steve
ditko you can actually see that same
steve ditko tag on the feast truck
throughout the movie mj's new york post
reads peter parker and his fighter
minions his hypnotic spider senses
seduced joan watson now while peter does
not really have hypnosis powers this
line does foreshadow how in this movie
the memory spell wipes the memory and
gaslights mj so in a way that ends up
happening as peter leans over to kiss mj
his textbook reads chemistry nice as
peter gets his college rejection letters
dummy reassembles the lego death star
set that peter and ned worked on in
homecoming but then at the end dummy
breaks it like ned did in that movie
this parallels the way the actual death
star was destroyed twice in the first
and the third movies of the star wars
trilogy as peter swoops down to mj's
shop his small silhouette in the sky
shows that he was in his iron spider
suit at first and then the nanobots
retracted on his descent but i guess he
was still holding that acceptance letter
all the while so the bots had to like
retract around his pinched fingers but
when he lands you can see mysterio
decals on both the lamppost and on the
nearby wall and there is another banner
for that statue of liberty renovation as
peter approaches the sanctum sanctorum
on the mailbox on the right is the
graffiti name romita for john romita
another spider-man comics writer and
then on the inside one of the
apprentices is played by emily fong long
time marvel studios production employee
wong portals in from upstairs you can
actually see the mechanical crimson
bands of cedar act that strange tossed
on kaiselius hanging on the wall there
wong i guess just didn't feel like
carrying his luggage downstairs makes
sense i would use sling rings for that
too now strange's mug reads oh for
[ __ ] sake and now that multiverse
madness is bringing in fox x-men later
patrick stewart professor x it truly is
for fox's sake that strange's world is
heating up he also wears the hoodie of
his alma mater colombia probably rubbing
it in for peter for getting rejected
from all these elite schools and showing
how strange stays connected with this
university and can just talk to them
something peter failed to even consider
trying peter says it's not about me i
mean this is really hurting a lot of
people peter actually unknowingly
repeats the ancient one's core lesson to
strange in the 2016 film it's not about
you and that is what makes strange want
to help peter wong warns strange about
his memory wipe spell called the runes
of cough call that spell travels the
dark borders between known and unknown
reality it's too dangerous
we've used it for a lot less do you
remember the full moon party at camertaj
no exactly indicating strange has used
this dangerous reality warping spell
before one of many violations that
probably led to the crisis of multiverse
madness wong then says just leave me out
of this which might be his way of saying
don't include me in the memory wipe
spell so that i can remember peter and
you can see behind wong is the
kameratosh courtyard that he's returning
to now peter parker's seeking doctor
strange's help this way to make everyone
forget that he's spider-man is a
reference to the one more day storyline
which actually ends in a similar place
with mj and peter's best friend
forgetting that he is spider-man after
asking strange to exclude mj from the
spell he then remembers ned oh my god
what is a ned yeah strange then pulls
out a chunk of the magic to observe ned
closely something he doesn't do for the
others maybe an indicator that ned has
the hidden sorcerer abilities and
strange can now see it here now when the
sanctum shakes and knocks over an
artifact in the lobby this is the same
delicate stupid thing that thor knocks
over in ragnarok then peter shouts
basically everyone that knew that i was
spiderman before should still know and
the moment peter gives us our rule by
which the multiverse men cross over
right before strange sees the purple
silhouette of the lizard the villain
that strange fights and has to catch off
screen later over peter's shoulder is
one of those other villains a hulking
figure at first i thought sandman but
based on the muscle definition i think
this is actually venom who also crossed
over into the mcu only briefly during
this event and behind lizard you can
start to see glowing dots for dozens
more just a hint right here early in the
movie that beyond these nearer
crossovers are even more multiversal
threats strange says you changed my
spell six times five times they
disagreed but peter asked strange to
exclude mj and ned in may and happy and
then everyone who knew before that's
five so strange actually might have
secretly adjusted the spell a sixth time
to exclude himself and wong because he
loves peter so much later as peter
glides down to the bridge i like how he
used his wingsuit webbing again it
retracts here but his head's up display
reads edith offline since the dodc shut
down the whole edith network which is
also why the voice has changed now now
when he retracts his armor his suit
underneath is wrinkled i just love that
little detail reflected how it was
crammed up against his body actually
later in this day you can see how his
blue button up is also super wrinkled
another cool detail i like how the vfx
artist adjusted his shadow on the side
of the car just to match his silhouette
changing peter passes a car with the
license plate s-e-y-s-i-d-p
and as we were clued in by the anagram
book we saw in peter's bedroom earlier
if you rearrange these you get the word
spidey's plural a clue for the multiple
spideys in this movie the mit woman's
car has a tag
63a5m3 a nod to the amazing spider-man
number three in 1963 the comic debut of
doc ock who makes his mcu debut in this
scene footage that the girl in the car
watches on her tablet is actually a
delayed live feed from the daily vehicle
helicopter you can see peter waving at
the camera on the tablet just as he did
a minute before peter also passes a taxi
numbered one two two eight a nod to
stanley's birthday of december 28 1922.
after peter's rambling speech the mit
woman responds you didn't rehearse that
did you peter yeah it is this failure
that later leads peter to script out and
rehearse what he wants to say to mj in
the final scene doc ock is revealed
[Music]
hello
peter hi now the music sampled here is
danny elfin's doc theme from 2004. you
see how his claws glow red this is how
that film indicated when the claws were
in control and he asks what have you
done with my machine i don't know what
you're talking about i don't know what
machine the power of the sun in the palm
of my hand calling back his line from
that film the power of the sun
in the palm of my hand when doc ock
lifts the concrete cylinder over him i
love how john watts briefly frames him
directly down the barrel of that
cylinder really cool shot composition
there and i like how peter gradually
learns to combat daca och as the fight
progresses like he webs down one of his
claws and then right after he webs a
second claw to the car door to try to
slow him down now really cool detail
here as peter suspends the suv over the
tracks in a wide shot of that bridge you
could see the name andrew graffiti on
the bridge column i'm pretty sure toby
and andrew's names appear everywhere in
this movie folks but then in a brief
shot back on the bridge another cool
detail no one else i think i spotted a
license plate reads 6306 asm for the
amazing spider-man number six in 1963
that was a debut of kurt connors the
lizard whom doctor strange is dealing
with at this moment in the sewers now
you can see there's a lot to talk about
when breaking down this amazing film so
to fuel me through this process i've
been trying my best to focus on some
interesting choices in my snacking game
and you can take your snacking on an
international adventure with our friends
at baksu baksu is a monthly subscription
service that delivers premium japanese
snacks and tea pairings straight from
japan to your door baksu partners with
family-owned snack makers to make their
original treats every monthly box is
themed this month's theme is sakura
season sakura is japanese for cherry
blossom and the cherry blossom is an
important cultural symbol in japan and
their blooming is a huge event so every
year people celebrate by gathering under
the trees for flower viewings called
hanami and they have picnics together
it's wonderful as you can see the box is
just packed with all sorts of limited
edition cherry blossom themed snacks and
this booklet that comes with it tells
you everything that's in the box what
part of japan it came from so this is a
sakura mochi from nagano in japan i just
love the texture of mochi i love how
squishy it is oh that's really good i
love mochi so muchy
it's like i'm eating a pillow that's
hugging my teeth back
so if you want to have your own sakura
celebration and support new rockstars
here click the link in the description
and use the code rockstars to get 15
off your order doc absorbs peter's
nanotech something that he's able to do
thanks to oscorp's nanotechnology i'm
something of a scientist myself i read
all your research on nanotechnology
really brilliant i'd like to thank harry
osborne and ask corp industries for
providing it and when doc tries to stab
him peter's nanotech shifts from his
helmet to his chest and they mixed in a
little ping sound effects then we know
dockhawk didn't stab him just skewered
his necktie
peter is able to pair his os with doc
arms since doc ock's arms are controlled
via neural link these smart arms are
controlled by my brain through a neural
link
nanowires feed directly into my
cerebellum and otto snaps at his claws
you don't listen to him you listen to me
i'll call back to the 2004 movie listen
to me now
now in the undercroft there are actually
a total of six cells eventually filled
by the five multiverse men of this movie
plus one more that is filled by the tree
that peter accidentally catches six
means that strange anticipated catching
venom as well and you can see how
strange his face is scratched now since
he had just fought the lizard doc ogg
asks what is this a birthday party
calling back tony stark referencing
strange's jimmy kimmel bit when they
first met what is your job exactly
besides making balloon animals around
the thawing sanctum you can see various
pages from spell books have been pinned
up on lamps to dry out never a good idea
to rip out pages from spellbooks folks
downstairs is a creepy doll that turns
to look at them on mj's tiktok is a
cosplayer dressed as a green elf looking
just like tom holland's character in
pixar's onward and mj also finds dr
strange's goatee trimming guard peter
tracks down electro and sandman sandman
helping peter because they were on good
terms at the end of the 2007 film now
one shot shows peter pulling together
multiple strands to beat electro
mirrored from a shot of andrew garfield
doing this to beat electro in the 2014
film now when electro and sandman get
trapped in the cells in the foreground
you can see the control panel showing
five lit up icons for each cell the
fifth one lit up for the tree there is a
sixth unlit button for the cell that
will soon be occupied by norman i'm
telling you one of these cells was going
to be for venom norman osborne shatters
his goblin mask the framing in the alley
matches the framing of toby peter
leaving his suit behind in the 2004 film
but in both cases those characters get
dragged back into the game but it is
interesting to note that goblin goes
straight for aunt may because assuming
he was transported from the raimi verse
right after learning peter was
spider-man at thanksgiving sometime
around that scene when he similarly
cowered in front of the mask in his home
his next move there was to go for the
heart which in that movie was also
ant-may the feast billboard tagged with
mysterio was right actually is a word
bubble that says meet queen's own
spider-man inside norman wears a green
coat and purple sweats his colors in the
comics but also this is stuff he clearly
got from the donation bin meaning that
he walked into this facility wearing his
goblin suit but aunt may still wanted to
help him he says someone's living in my
house
oscar doesn't exist yes oscar does not
exist in the mcu making it likelier that
peter's spider bite might have come from
stark tech i made a whole video about
that check it out it may mean while he's
wearing a blue jumpsuit with a red sash
throughout this movie she's almost
always wearing spider-man's red and blue
colors goblin steals donuts in the
background signaling he's still in his
shifty goblin survival mode actually and
peter says this isn't my problem peter
not your problem calling back toby's
line in the 2002 film that led to uncle
ben's death i missed the part where
that's my problem j jonah jameson's
chiron reads why does spider-man hate
national landmarks showing the
washington monument in the tower bridge
now if you look closely you can see that
feast truck actually used to be for the
forest hills moving company forest hills
queens is historically peter parker's
neighborhood strange shows them the
machina de cadavers its name coming from
the crystal of cadavers in the comics
used to try to resurrect the dead in a
strange spider-man team-up issue in this
case it will doom these men to their
deaths to make them literal cadavers
strange pushes peter's soul out of his
body but peter's able to use his spider
sense to control his limbs wavy lines
stretch out from his head which is how
his fighter sense looks in the comics
and an animation i also love the detail
that his astral soul's shoes are untied
just showing peter's inner hot mess
nature strange throws the cloak of
levitation around peter giving us the
caped spider-man that we saw in the what
if comics and in episode five of what if
now on the newsstand is the people
magazine interview with liz allen from
homecoming he's a liar which i assume is
a defense piece for her father adrian
toomes since peter got him arrested
something maybe we could revisit morbius
but i like how the subhead reads liz
allen's intimate past with parker
despite these two never actually kissed
in homecoming it was in the trailer but
not in the final cut of the movie so
really this whole article is a
distortion in the mirror dimension peter
tumbles down the high line of manhattan
and he passes a billboard showing a
t-rex skeleton it's an interesting
parallel to strange's coming multiverse
tumble past an actual t-rex on the train
dr strange's eye of agamotto briefly
opens and illuminates showing that this
artifact still has some power beyond
being a mere time stone fanny pack
something else that we will see in
multiverse madness peter uses the
geometry of archimedean spirals to
string up strange shortly after strange
mentioned the grand calculus of the
multiverse geometry versus calculus just
showing how peter used the simpler math
to defeat his overthinking rival
norman says the line you know
i'm something of a scientist myself
peter and ended their handshake from
homecoming but now ned produces a spark
out of that sling ring because he's a
sorcerer peter takes them on to happy's
condo actually a deleted scene would
have shown them in the elevator together
bummed we missed out on that on the way
in we see them on the security monitor
elektra causes some distortion on the
feed and then he uses his hand to zap
the tv on where we see a news poll on
that statue of liberty renovation
showing 67 percent of new yorkers
disapprove of it on the wall in happy's
back room is the name slots for dance
lot another big spider-man comics writer
that stark fabricator is the same kind
of machine that peter used to 3d print
his new suit on the jet and far from
home and it is powered by the specific
era of the arc reactor in iron man 2
when it had that triangular inlay tony
stark later replaced this with new
versions showing why these old ones
would be stored may and doc ock briefly
connect in the kitchen and not to them
getting married at one point in the
comics yup that happened sandman's
holding up a framed photo of morgan
stark reminding him of his daughter
penny who would be around the same age
peter plugs in the new inhibitor chip to
doc ock the claw lights go from red to
white as they did in the 2004 film to
indicate auto regaining control and
notice on the fabricator peter created
profiles for each of his patients c
connors m dylan and osborne but only
max's cure is listed as complete since
as we see later when may tries to plug
norman with the antidote it does not
work auto chats with norman how does it
feel norman
you're about to become whole again no
more darker half
just you
just me yes defoe uses his darker goblin
voice there teasing the goblin is about
to make his move also notice as he turns
around he is suddenly sweating bullets
despite not sweating that much seconds
before this and so peter's spider sense
activates again like we saw on the
bridge we get another great dolly zoom
camera move now behind him on the left
here is actually howard stark's expo
bottle from iron man 2 but the first
person peter passes in his trance is
norman the source of the danger the
camera only pulls away from peter when
may enters the frame and she's burning
sage and she says what is it peter so
this whole sequence starts with norman
and it ends with may notice how peter's
left hand just slightly begins to raise
to wed norman who only goes back down
when sandman asks what's happening
distracting peter over on the right and
in that moment of distraction norman
moves across the room to dummy which
even doc och views is suspicious based
off his expression after peter whips him
goblin reveals himself these are not
curses they're gifts gifts and curses a
call back to the 2002 film line this is
my gift
my curse also notice how devoe now shows
the gap in his teeth which he did not
have when he smiled before because in
the 2002 film william defoe wore veneers
as norman osborne but shifted to his
normal teeth when he transformed into
the goblin as peter fights him we see
happy also has a painting of tony's
roadster hot rod tell you what
throw a little hot rod red in there yes
that should help you keep a low profile
and goblin smiles more and more as peter
punches him showing how each hit makes
him stronger and crazier so goblin hits
may with his glider and bombs the place
on his way out he slices the daily bugle
van telecom tower which actually does
jameison a favor because in his really
shitty broadcast after this incident
he's able to lie and say that this was
all spider-man's doing not goblins and
then mae drops the big adage
and with great power there must also
come great
responsibility they actually used the
original version of this quote there
must also come from amazing fantasy 15
when stan lee spoke at his exposition
you can actually see this quote on
marissa tome's title card in the closing
credits and as she dies peter says okay
it's just me and you
calling back when may said this to peter
in homecoming just lay it out it's just
me and you which i read as may referring
to ben's recent death it was just the
two of them then and just the two of
them now now in ned stannis house they
also have that photo of ned and mj from
homecoming showing how all three of
these friends had a different copy of
this and we see it now because ned and
mj really just want to be with peter i
think all this was intended to be a back
to the future photo style prop to show
how these two did have a version of
their life without peter in it now lola
also has a sewing machine but just to be
clear this is a different sewing machine
than the one peter has at the end of the
film andrew garfield spider-man enters
the film string theory
multi-dimensional reality
and matter displacement
all real
yeah
[Music]
yeah the little piano notes under there
is actually james horner's amazing
spider-man theme i just love the meta
word play between andrew and mj why do i
need to crawl around cause this is not
enough this is plenty no it's not yes it
is no it's not it is oh yeah as if one
past spider-man is not enough which mj
doubles down on yeah i i guess you just
keep doing until we find the real one
ouch now when andrew hops down from the
ceiling the sling ring portal has now
pivoted to face him turning on its axis
from the direction it was facing before
just showing how ned opened this portal
in order to find peter and so peter is
how the portal orients itself in the
room then toby maguire enters
great it's just some random guy
hello yes the music is danny elfman's
spider-man theme and after teaching
peter some critical lessons about
dealing with his grief the three peters
rallied to engineer some curious okay so
uh connors marco dillon and um
yes he cannot bring himself to say
osborne's name because deep down he
doesn't want to cure him yet which toby
double checks i think i can make an
anti-serum for dr osborne
i've been thinking about it a long time
gotta cure all of them
right i also like the implication that
toby has been losing sleep over wishing
he could have cured osborne over all
these years instead of watching them die
and when toby talks about harry osborn
watch andrew here do you have a best
friend too
i did
you did
he died in my arms
after he tried to kill me
intro goes from pity for toby's friend
dying in his arms to surprise and
empathy for his harry also trying to
kill him and we get the meme peter
oh sorry sorry
yeah they all point at each other which
even the movie script directs as memes
when toby webs the stool notice he still
has his scars on his wrist from the remy
films and again andrew's reaction is the
best you can't do that huh no how on
earth does that even anyway we're
getting sidetracked look this is where
we're gonna do that it takes him a solid
beat for andrew to finally take his eyes
off that scar andrew cracks toby's back
less deadly than when he did it to gwen
they're referenced fighting venom and
spider-man 3 and thanos and rhino and
the amazing spider-man 2 and toby says
but it's just a self-talk maybe we
should no listen cause you're you're
amazing just to take it in for a minute
yeah yeah yeah
you are amazing then electro appears and
the bolts form the shape of electro's
classic mask from the comics on his face
you actually see this shape again later
when he's zapping andrew ned is unable
to close his portal and that might be
because the other two times he opened
the portal the purpose he was seeking to
find peter was met so those portals
closed on their own but now ned's real
purpose deep down is to help this battle
he can't take his mind off the battle
and allow that portal to close at first
the three peters failed to work together
andrew swings through tom's webbing and
then tries to web the machinery but webs
toby in the face
yeah toby says gross despite andrew's
webbing being artificial unlike his
webbing that comes out of his body tom
says i was in the avengers the avengers
yeah that's great thank you what is that
well you don't have the avengers is that
a bad are you in a band calling back how
bruce compared the avengers to the
beatles in infinity war broke up like a
band like like the beatles and then when
they leap each peter's jump is unique to
his respective era toby does a double
front flip tom does a frog pose and
andrew does a clean nose dive and then
as they swing around toby does an under
the legs thwhip as he would do in his
movies and then tom turns around to web
his two brothers to sling them along
with him and when he does this he uses
the side roll move that cap did when he
was fighting peter in civil war fighting
but actually helping him and then at the
end of the sequence they land in the
order of their eras toby first andrew
second tom third during the battle
andrew webs up the lizard to restrain
him but it takes a while for the lizard
to break out of it compared to the 2012
movie when lizard was able to tear out
of the webbing seconds later might be
showing how andrew spent these years
strengthening his webbing after
you know
there you go
[Music]
lizard attacks mj and ned in the
classroom recalling his fight with
andrew in the high school in the 2012
film doc ock is able to restrain elektro
since his claws were designed to be
impervious to energy spikes and then
after notice how toby is holding his
chest because unlike andrew his suit was
not designed to be shockproof ned
finally brings doctor strange back i've
been dangling over the grand canyon for
12. i know i know in a way this is a bit
of payback for strange making loki free
fall for a half hour in ragnarok i have
been falling
for 30 minutes goblin shouts can the
spiderman come out to play calling back
his line in the 2002 film can spiderman
come out to play now when strange
lassoes the box and pulls it away you
can see goblin with both hands on the
box smiling because he just slipped in
that pumpkin bomb he cuts one of doc
ock's arms and leaves them with
[Music]
the explosion caused mj to fall from the
scaffolding framing her just like gwen's
death drop except here turned on the
side and andrew retakes the plunge
except this time he focuses more on the
leap instead of on his webbing he
catches her in his arms instead of
clutching her with the web to avoid that
whiplash you know that one
as peter fights norman on that shield he
leaps up at one point and punches down
denting the metal which totally would
have caved in a skull he picks up the
glider to stab him with it the same way
goblin died in the 2002 film but also
evoking cap bringing down the shield on
tony in civil war a parallel that's even
more obvious since they are fighting
upon cap's shield but toby stops tom
from killing goblin no words just
doesn't want the kid to grow rageful and
bitter but goblin stabs him and tom
literally turns his body from one side
to the other he was in killing mode but
now he turns the cheek andrew sees this
and assists him with the serum
hey nice catch
nice throw toby's okay saying yeah i'm
gonna
step oh god referring to when harry
osborn stabbed him in the rainy films
purple cracks in the sky open up i've
broken this down before but the visible
silhouettes include madame webb getting
her own movie the superior spider-man
armor with multiple arms craven the
hunter getting his own movie scorpion
the original comics form black cat and
then later rhino and then i figure
everyone keeps calling mysterio based
off of the head but i don't think so
this guy walks with more of a timid step
and has a slender build i think this is
actually miles morales peter tells
strange to go through with the spell and
they say goodbye to each other thank you
sir
call me stephen
thank you steven yeah
still feels weird calling back their
banter of course earlier in this movie
but also the very first time they met in
infinity war and joked about their real
names i'm peter by the way dr strange oh
you're using their made up names um i'm
spider-man then peter hugs the other
peters
thank you thank you thank you thank you
a hug that was improvised by tom holland
to thank these past two eras of
spider-man so after the spell goes
through peter returns to the peter pan
donut shop a name with greater
significance now for a peter who has to
watch others through a window living
their lives without him mj attends to
this older patron whom the script calls
a stan lee look-alike i suppose this is
meant to be the film's stan lee cameo
but really just to make us do a double
take and evoke deja vu the way mj feels
in the scene the script also states that
mj is meant to watch peter go with quote
a lingering sense of recognition this
plus the fact that she is still wearing
that broken black dahlia necklace tells
us that some part of her still remembers
peter anime's gravestone has the birth
and death dates covered by flowers which
could be a nod to tony stark always
questioning how young she really is back
in civil war and the quote reads when
you help someone you help everyone which
is actually what is written on her grave
in the spider-man ps4 game and the
epilogue peter moves into a new
apartment rent is due on the first of
the month
don't be late yes his squaller apartment
evokes peter's crappy flat in the rainy
films and while the landlord's voice is
not mr ditkovich the fact that he
reminds peter of the rant is definitely
meant to remind us of that guy we see
that peter is studying for the ged
meaning peter's academic records must
have been wiped or warped since if you
think about it much of his midtown high
identity was really wrapped up in his
spider-man identity at this point i did
do another video breaking down how
exactly reality was warped and who
remembers what i highly recommend you
check it out on peter's table is the we
are happy to serve you cup that mj gave
peter in the cafe and by the way that
coffee cup is just a generic new york
area coffee cup that appears in
productions of literally everything shot
in that city it's not a reference to
hawkeye or a daredevil this cup is in
everything it's like saying a red solo
cup is an easter egg but what is a cool
detail peter has that lego palpatine
figurine which was the first line we
heard spoken by ned in this trilogy in
homecoming and peter has a new suit that
he has stitched together diy finally
without having avengers to build his
tech for him and design wise it's made
of a brighter fabric clearly inspired by
the designs of the other two spider-men
actually the closing credits show his
sketches of a new logo as he swings
through rockefeller's center failing to
make a cameo in the final battle of
hawkeye we get this awesome closing
frame almost a jump scare because he
zooms it right in on our faces giving us
an extreme close-up of his new mask but
up close like this we can see it is
textured in a porous fabric gone are
those mechanical eyepieces this is just
a cloth mask giving us a new beginning a
fresh start
baby that is everything i spotted in
this high residential release of no way
home but folks there is still the 4k
version coming next month and there's
gonna be a lot of deleted scenes
commentary lots of bonus footage there's
me a lot to talk about this film and
we'll be revisiting again so be sure to
subscribe to new rockstars you can
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos check out our merch store epic
hero shop for lots of great designs to
support this channel directly thank you
so much for watching bye
[Music]
you